so today's topic
dear pewdiepie i think you're gonna
watch this video because you watched the
first part and you said you would
hell yeah i can't help but notice that
your reactions to our videos get way
more views
the reaction to the video gets more
fusion
if that ain't a [ __ ]
of course you would ask you to buy to
review your videos
in his reviews
you know to be fair a couple of our
videos have more views than their
originals too
like that one where you made fun of that
white girl was like oh this is uh
bullying you all heard him you all
haters
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but it was a girl that was not
saying
i'll be just flexed you know what i'm
saying flex bruh flex
i don't got 100 million subscribers i'm
saying yeah no i'm saying we out here he
got 100 million subscribers
i'm pretty sure you got 100 million
goddamn that's a lot of [ __ ]
i can't help but notice that your
reactions to our videos get
way more views
she has a hole in this sock a big
[ __ ] in his sock
goddamn i feel for my man this is what
they say
he must have not white boy going to
first yeah my black dude because you
know i mean no racism
in the third third yeah yeah he's
staying last second
yeah because he wore shorts uh this
[ __ ] thought he was going swimming
uh and i think short man probably gonna
go he's short i think short man gonna go
fourth or third
so short man don't win yeah yeah short
man
all right i think i'm good here
do you wanna start with introductions or
something sure yeah you could do that
jeremy is my name fun fact used to live
in texas
uh but i didn't like it i'm jorge
okay all right hold up before we start
okay so what i heard
um from like some of the comments and
some of the videos that people sent me
that apparently
remember when the girl was like when one
guy was like oh yeah based off their
personality was
like you didn't even hear nothing
ranking the girls i actually think we
were doing it mostly by personality
you didn't even talk to the girl what
the [ __ ] are you talking about bro turns
out they were listening
to their whole deliberation beforehand
so they didn't know
but the way they edited they made them
look goofy
right of course so we have to assume
that they heard that the ladies are also
listening so astrophysics
you know what that means ching chang our
ranking let's go
throw it in the trash it doesn't matter
yeah it doesn't matter if you're does it
matter if you're short no
if you do an astronaut i think they're
going to be like cause he's short he
seems like an [ __ ] he's short but
he's not ugly
yeah but he's like i like going to the
gym and look tanning in youtube like i
think
yeah my recent college graduate
studying political science well she i
guess first of all right off the bat
i think i don't know about you guys but
this guy looks like a young vin diesel
over to the front and have you guys seen
his eyes
what yeah look at him because you got
blue
no you saw what he did have you guys
seen his eyes oh look at his eyes
yeah would you look at that what'd you
look at look at his eyes
this mother look
who the [ __ ] down there
stories down have you seen his eyes
where
oh i can't see that far got there he he
didn't mean to but that was how it came
hey can you jump i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry anytime you do to a grown man what
you do to a child at a playground
who's just got a booboo oh i like his
eyes
he got shiniers he's probably the most
fit yeah
he chose a good shirt i'll make my way
over here then
manlets when will they ever learn
manlets yeah
short men oh wow
i think you guys should duke it out and
just say what you're a three i feel like
i'm tall enough
i'm the shortest guy bro
i'm fine with that no you look like you
put a lot of work in yourself i thought
he was gonna be number one to be honest
so for me he at least has to be a three
or two i
i don't want to be like rude or blunt
but he kind of looks like a frat boy
so i think he should be like a three can
i put a word in for myself that i'm not
a bad boy
no i feel like we should switch i feel
like we should switch i mean that's
right
i think you're up there personally i'm
content with being four
four or five i stick with five you're a
pretty good looking guy
i say you're i think you're pretty cute
too boy
hey yo yo [ __ ] somebody get a folding
church
[Laughter]
learning more about their personalities
i wasn't going to argue
that they're least attractive than me i
personally feel that you should rank
should be in two higher three if you
guys i don't know the cameras can pick
it up but i woke up with
blemishes today i've always had problems
with my image
especially when i was younger like
around middle school i got like horrible
horrible acne
you know i'm like you know he reminds me
hey remember the chocolate bar guy for
the acne commercials
people saw eat too many chocolate bars
or something
well people don't see the real me right
they just see my acne problem people
think that i eat too many chocolate
bars or that i don't wash my face yeah i
tried
many things i've tried everything but
just nothing works
um my brother says i'll probably grow
out of it but
i don't think so no it's hard to believe
now that it will actually go away
there are solutions call for a free
informational video
this is where it crashes yeah because
he's so outspoken
but he's like yeah you know i'm not
really you know confident [ __ ] like
that but but but you're so confident
you're calling in [ __ ]
you kind of took the control of this
whole conversation but it can be
assertive
in social situations and also view
themselves as not being attractive
because like you said childhood matters
childhood matters stuff it was like the
scars and stuff so that always like
really like kind of hurt my confidence
yeah that seems like a big deal to you
but none of us like even notice that you
got to be too though
i just no no because you're bigger like
you can't even tell man
no
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
when i saw when the guys were ranking
each other
it's like a first impression type of
thing so basing off how you look
and the conversation that we heard for a
little
time need to see their booties
let's go i need to see their booties
yeah
she's writing i mean i'm not mad i guess
okay i think it's just like how
hopefully she can say that without being
seen as weird or creepy
no we can say that we shut the [ __ ] up
with that yo girl can i see your ass
real quick
[Laughter]
okay you know the party went yeah let's
see that is like there was nobody
i'm like yeah let's see that nothing
nothing okay all right
number one we need to get the tender
little sweetheart that is that is wrong
right now and get him out of that spot
he i feel like he he would give you
flowers like he'd go to your doorstep
by far if i was sick i'd call him to
take care of
flat out oh roy's they're not even gonna
rate this is how they feel
see and i think they're they think
they're doing him a favor
but now it just looks like you're pity
voting for him which makes him look more
pathetic yeah
and this is what happens when i say
people think like kindness is the great
thing no sometimes being kind
is actually cruel because you're not
telling the person the truth
you lying to someone is not kindness
that's just you stroking your own ego to
make yourself look like a good person i
would call him the
no you wouldn't yeah know that [ __ ] you
win sweetheart
oh i love him i wanted him to talk more
i felt like all the boys talked over
poor roy
honestly i love little baby roy he just
got shoved little baby roy
if ever a girl call me baby someone oh
[ __ ] oh no
no imagine you're a girl that we call yo
hey baby girl
little baby something come on now ah
it's like that one time when i was on a
date with a girl and she was like you
know what i but you're so soft and i was
like
that's sushi because we know that's not
a good no that's not a good
time and i was like this poor kid
attractiveness for me and as a general
whole
i was like who am i wanting to go hang
out with right now like if we were done
after this and we wouldn't
be like why don't you grab coffee my
number one would be
spill the tea kalen he looks like a
bootleg
michael b jordan so he would go first
because we love michael b jordan but
astrophysics
yeah he has a nice haircut his eyes
i felt like i had a very friendly vibe
from him just his like eyes and his
smile
i thought sam was the most attractive to
me
he wasn't striving to be number one he
was just like
place me right here we go see see
this is why hey they do this thing in
public where they start active things
that attractiveness have nothing to do
with it
but you know what it just goes to show
you how different these two that try to
rate each other
but here's the problem i have they'll
say i find this attractive
but who they'll date will not be that no
it's not going to be that
all right they'll be like oh baby roy
that you don't want baby boys
you don't want to babysit nothing and
i'll take that
i feel like he's friends with his mom
yeah but i feel like
he also might like cheat on you no
yeah let's try to think of something
drastic here
trump supporters
i feel like he probably has a bad temper
or something he punches drywall
when he gets angry caitlyn gave her one
who's your two three four five
what do these things have to do with
attractiveness this is just all a bunch
of prejudice
if i look at a girl and i'm like she's a
seven based off of her looks it's just
based on what i'm seeing visually that's
it
these people are looking at it and
reading into it personality it's like
looking at an asian person but
you probably eat dog it's the same thing
you're good at math
what am i watching this is brutal it was
one two three four five
one two three four four five wait who
yeah you said she said
one two three four five see what i'm
saying
fourth and fourth let me see you go back
here
listen and that's why let the record
show last episode what did i say
if it was me my sister's going first
straight up i am out of that
one blue sweater blue
um two
three four five just because i'm very
big on height i would go
one two
three four five what
sorry yeah
what yeah yeah what are you talking
about okay
she's injecting her politics into it
well you know whatever it's all good
yeah i mean i feel like i like a guy
who's not
so skinny just because i like you know
protection
i understand i don't want to break them
i really like his eyes okay he's for
sure one
[Music]
yeah or two or three see i think her
hair would be two no
see let's go [ __ ] let's go
be adorable i don't really like
anybody's outfits today
anyway i understand we're all
comfortable right
it's over there yeah yeah
[Music]
i would just like to say what a little
angel right what a little
angel get somewhere not in file
look at his little wings protect him i
care more about what
the girls thought than the guys but
that's just my own opinion
wait so can we just move up because i he
can't be there yeah can we put him in
third put his
switch your little angel for personality
yeah white shirt and white and green i
would switch switch
it he's like you heard the ladies
i kind of feel like maybe they should
swim yeah
i am 100 okay with this lineup i feel
like i'm okay with this
with the black guy last yeah
i don't want to be mean but i didn't
find any of them attractive so it was
kind of a lot harder than i anticipated
outside of this i would not have looked
at any of the guys
i would walk past each one of them but
i like that girl she didn't lie a single
second i said no she
nah no she was real i didn't matter i
didn't i ain't mad at her
live your life girlfriend what did you
think
i mean they just try to be nice that's
what it is
we're not gonna get something out of it
because they just try to be nice
essentially
they try to be nice not real nice
because the show's gonna be aired and
it's more about how i'm gonna look than
how they're gonna look you know what i
mean
yeah the point of the game was to rape
people but they thinking
itself you know what i'm supposed to
rate them but how am i gonna look
so yes i'm supposed to look up how
they're going to look but how
am i going to look rating them on how
they look
so they will base themselves on that but
you know i feel yeah
except the black girl black girl's like
hey they're going to judge me no matter
what
yeah so yeah my thing is this
it's fine if you take personality into
account when you think attractiveness
but don't lie don't don't substitute
likability with attractiveness
just because someone is likable does not
mean that you are actually
attracted to them in a romantic sense
right you could feel for someone oh i'm
rooting for that guy and still never
want to be and a lot of you do that
a lot of you be like he's just so nice
and guys know what it feels like man
i seem to be so likable what's wrong
it's because you're not bangable
no you're just nice and soft
and that's never good yeah so that was
my problem with like the way that they
rated stuff but
otherwise um yeah
what did you guys think what did y'all
think get in the comments and
pontificate
yo you wanna pontificate
so it's only fair that jubilee media
collaborates with pewdiepie
maybe the audience can suggest some
concepts in the comments section below
for now enjoy the episode damn these
people are out here just making requests
like this like we're super publicly
i i am are you mad at it it's like
they're you know what
yeah i respect do you want to work with
them
to improve their [ __ ] yeah
no would you
you would that means he would what do
you mean i would he totally would
who do i even want to collaborate with
in general who have you accepted the
collaboration yeah who
me yeah exactly yeah
you know how to be how many times you
know what i don't know exactly i'm
trolling yeah
yeah you know i'm trying yeah you are
can we and i'm just like no or sometimes
just like i'll do it he won't mean
because i'm on my drake [ __ ] yeah i
ain't mad at you no new friends
no you friends no new friends
i just i don't even listen to drake
records i just use them to meme
yeah i ain't mad at it yeah him and
jacquies they're big memes yeah
but drink a bigger meme yeah whatever
yeah whatever digress